good evening I'm dan quayle and welcome
to a kinder gentler Oskar tonight we've
been saying no longer the winner is
it's the award goes to someone else and
I was here last year I was sitting out
there like many of you and waiting
waiting like that and knowing that yes
yes it might be me and they opened the
envelope and Michael Douglas really I'm
so very very happy for you I really am
and they come in real close and you have
to smile but he wouldn't be better if
you could just be really honest and go
Michael hey oh no no no but that's why a
year ago I was nominated I lost and now
I'm dressed as a giant rat
I feel like some sort of ad for steroids
you take steroids no sir do not hello
I'm Michael Eisner tonight's Disney
movie star Sylvester Stallone as bambo
I'm here for a reason dressed like this
four more years to present a very
special Oscar if not I don't know why
the ears look Vincent van mouths now
I would like to talk for a brief moment
about cartoon consciousness you never
see Robert De Niro's face on a watch no
I would like to bring out now a man from
a movie a very special movie we're
giving award to tonight behind every
great man they say there's a great
behind no that's Tammy Faye Baker I'm
sorry I would like to bring out to help
me this evening the voice of Roger
Rabbit Charles Fletcher
thank you very much you know Robin
because of the amazing success of Who
Framed Roger Rabbit toons are now being
taken seriously in Hollywood and soon
toons are going to be offered serious
dramatic roles that's right but be
during a sequel starring Roger Rabbit
and Mickey Mouse in rain mouths we do
that well we can also see maybe cartoon
characters on Broadway Elmer Fudd in
streetcar named desire stair
Mickey Mouse will be able to explore the
character parts hello my name is Mickey
Mouse
welcome to the Mouse Club mi see see
what I mean Katy why why because I said
so that's why we're here this evening to
present a very very special award but
first we also believe the tunes have a
power toon power because toons could one
day rule the world they could be
political leaders right that's a good
idea
hey that's the way to go whose political
leaders hey how about the DA Qaddafi da
that's it hey maybe you Sarah read a
mousy poon Ayatollah come out see that's
the one hey goofy Bush hey Dan Quayle no
that's okay mr. Tuvok hey go away from
that one outta here
this is our special achievement war
that's being presented to Dick Williams
through his incredible Direction Who
Framed Roger Rabbit he has ability to
create cartoon characters that move with
the Grace and agility of find answers
and to project the great emotional depth
of our finest actuals ditto
dr. bet it did it did it this way in a
bet
he drew my wife and she's got a nice
smile he gives him life he gives them
smarts he gives them smarts and it gives
them life too bad he didn't draw my
voice
so again so I guess what we're trying to
say this way I'm just here to stay for
the other six for me to you visit
William is a tune - ladies and gentlemen
remember this great cartoon voices
without great animation would simply be
radio
thank you very much members of the
Academy on Carl Bell I have to thank
first Steven Spielberg for having the
enormous prestige to Midwife the whole
thing and get all those different
competing cartoons in the same movie
then to Jeffrey Katzenberg who kept his
cool under tremendous duress and thank
God or I wouldn't be here tonight also
when I met Bob Zemeckis first in the
first 10-15 minutes I said boy you know
exactly you know exactly what you want
I'll be your pencil and so Bob should
have anyway it's an awful lot of Bob in
these and we had some marvelous
animators on the film and and I have to
single out one who I used as pillars he
held up bits of that film like bunch of
pillars and that's andreas tasia
thank you thanks the best is yet to come